التطورات والميدانيه امتدت ايضا الى
مقاطعه زبرجيا حيث قالت سلطاته مليتوبل
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه دمرت
ثلاثه مستودعات ذخيره وعتادا للقوات
الروسيه واصابت مئه وثلاثين جنديا روسيا
في قصف شنته على المدينه من جانب قال
الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تقصف
البنى التحتيه في مسماه جزء المحرر من
زبرجيا ودمرت تسعه عشره منزلا للمزيد حول
اخره هذه التطورات الميدانيه تنضم الينا
من دنيا مراسله الجزيره سلام خضر ومعنا من
نيكولايز مراسل الجزيره تامر رئيس ماضي
وسنبدا معك تامر واخر تطورات الجبهه
الجنوبيه ولسيامه ما يحدث في خرسان
التطورات متسارعه في عموم المقاطعات هل
جنوبيه ال سي تحديدا في خيرسون لكن اسمحي
لي ان ابدا من هنا من ميكولايف حيث يتواصل
القصفه الروسي لليوم الثاني على التوالي
في منطقه اشتاكو هذه المنطقه المهمه
الاستراتيجيه الساحليه التي تغذي كثير من
مناطق ميكو لايف بالمياه القصف وفقا
للقوات الاوكرانيه يجري على البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه تحديدا تحديدا خزانات
المياه وما ادى الى انقطاعات كبيره في
المياه وفي الكهربا ايضا هنا في ميكولاتات
تحاول السلطات استعادتها بشكل تدريجي
للمناطق هنا في لكنها تطورات ايضا متسارعه
في غير سون خلال الساعات الاخيره قالت
السلطات الاوكرانيه بان القوات الروسيه
نفذت 39 هجوما همم قصفا على مناطق متعدده
من خيرسون وهذا القصف يجري من الناحيه
اليمنى من نهر دنيبر التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه وتفصل غير سون الى جزئين
لكن في المقابله الاوكرانيه تقول بانها
تكثف من قصفها لمستودعاتها دخيره لمراكز
تواجد القوات الروسيه على الضفه اليمنى من
نهر دنيبر هذه القوات التي كانت انسحبت من
المدينه خيرسون خلال الايام الماضيه نتحدث
عن اكثر من اسبوعين حتى هذه اللحظه ننقل
في الحقيقه عن مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه
توقعاتها بان بان هذه القوات الموجوده على
نهر دنيبر القوات الروسيه لن تصمد طويلا
الحديث عن ثلاثه اسابيع التقديرات
الاوكرانيه ربما عن ثلاثه اسابيع اربعه
اسابيع في الحد الاعلى لانها تقول بانها
تقوم بقصف الطرقات طرقات
الامدادات كما تسميها التي همم يعني تقوم
روسيا بمد القوات العسكريه الروسيه هناك
عندنا نهر دنابر عن طريق شبه جزيره
القرموط تقول بانها تقصف هذه الطرقات
التطورات سريعا ايضا متلاحقه في زبرج
الجنوبيه البلاد تقول السلطات في همم زبرج
الاوكرانيه بانها قصفت مدينه ملي بهذه
المدينه الاستراتيجيه التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه الحديث عن اكثر من 130
جريحا في اوساط الجنود الروسي الاضافه الى
مستودعات للذخيره والحديث ايضا عن قصف
تقوم به القوات الروسيه في منطقه نيكول في
ريف ديني برو وسط جنوبي البلاد هذه
المدينه تتعرض لقصف متواصل الحديث عن اكثر
من 70 قذيفه روسيه طيله هذا اليوم سلام
خضر في دنياك ما حجم التقدم الذي تقول
القوات الروسيه انها تحرسه في همم في تلك
المنطقه
ال سي بحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فان
القوات الروسيه تحقق تقدما في مناطق
القتال خاصه جنوب دانيت ولكن لم تفصح عن
حجم هذا التقدم ولا عن المواقع التي وصلت
اليها جلمه اعلن من وزاره الدفاع على لسان
الناطق ايجار تحدث عن ان القوات الروسيه
وتمكنت من صد محاولات هجوم كثيفه من قبل
الجانب الاوكراني جنوب دانياتسك تحديدا في
محاوله لاستعاده مواقع كانت قد خسيرتها
ولكن القوات الروسيه بحسب وزاره الدفاع
اجبرت القوات الاوكرانيه الى التراجع لما
بعض الخطوط التي كانت دفعتها اليها اعلان
وزاره الدفاع عن ما يجري هنا جنوب
دانيات ال سي يترافق مع تجدد عند القصف
المدعي ونحن نتحدث اليكم الان نسمعوا
تبادل للقذف رغم سوء الاحوال الجويه كنا
نقول في وقت سابق من اليوم ان الاحوال
الجويه والضباب الكثيف قد يؤدي الى وقف
القصف المدفعي او على الاقل تراجعه ولكن
في هذه الاثناء تعود هذه يعود تبادل القصف
بين الجانبين من الواضح ان جنوب منطقه
دنيتك يا منطقه شديده القتال وتشهد همم
محاولات من كلا الطرفين الروسي للتقدم
والاكراني في محاوله لاستعاده ما خسيرته
القوات الاوكرانيه هذا هنا في دنياك اما
في لوغانس ايضا تحدثت الدفاع الروسيه عن
صدي محاولات هجوم اوكرانيه مدعومه بمجموعه
تكتيكيه في خرسان وفي خيار كيف قالت
الدفاع الروسيه انها وجهها ضربات جويه لما
وصفاتها بالمواقع بمواقع القياده وايضا
مواقع اطلاق القذائف والصواريخ قالت انها
دمرت احد المخازن الخاصه بي صواريخ هاي
مارس وايضا الحقت اضرار كبيره بالقوات
الاوك شكرا لكما سلام خضر من دنياك وتامرس
ماضي من نيكولايف